do Clevelanders need a public option
when it comes to things like golfing in
farmers markets now of course not then
why do they keep paying for them I think
got me brother we're here at the West
Side Market a vital part of Cleveland
since 1912 what's the kind of historic
role of the West Side Market in
Cleveland as an institution or a place
of business West Side Market is a great
place to buy groceries but the vendors
who rent stalls here have plenty of
complaints so what needs to get done
that's not
and when you wash your hands you have to
move your hands like that to buy a
faucet so who's running this place
anyway my name is George Braddock and I
am the manager of the West Side Market
George works for the city of Cleveland
which owns and operates the West Side
Market are you happy with the way the
city runs the building and runs the
market in an age when most roastery
stores are open 24 hours a day the West
Side Market is only open four days a
week does that make good business sense
it does the does the market make money
for the city no we heard a similar story
at Highland Hills Golf Course which is
also owned by the city even though the
Greens fees are some of the lowest in
the city play has been down in recent
years between 2001 and 2005 the number
of rounds played at Highland Hills
dropped by nearly 50%
I think he's got closer to change look
at the grass and tears
some of it is not cut and some of it
it's no surprise that golfers don't want
to play it courses that aren't
well-maintained for only a few bucks
more per Ram Clevelanders can go to
Briarwood are privately owned course
just down the road from Seneca
Cleveland's other municipally-owned Golf
Course how does your course compared to
the two courses at the city of Cleveland
owns and operates it's well above theirs
do you guys go at the Cleveland horses
who knows
our golf course is a kind of core
business that a city should be figuring
out how to run and to be expert at um
probably not because you'd like to
actually have something that's spin into
business or knows more about it is it
surprising to you that the publicly
owned and operated golf courses and
markets are inferior to the privately
owned ones doesn't surprise you we're
all familiar with the saying good enough
for government work
but maybe Cleveland taxpayers deserve
better than good enough is there any
evidence that private firms can do a
better job whether we're talking about
running a golf course or paving city
streets we went to Chicago a city that
has privatized a number of its assets
recently through a process called
public-private partnerships this entire
section underneath them the new
millenium park which was built with
largely private donations and private
funds he's the largest underground
parking system in the world that system
has all it was formerly owned by the
government by the city and now it's been
privatized Michael Smith is an attorney
at Baker & McKenzie over the past few
years Michael has represented firm
bidding to lease city assets the first
privatization was the Skyway said large
privatization was the Skyway which is
just out there on the horizon and then
the parking meters along Columbus and
Michigan Avenue and then throughout the
rest of the city were privatized and
after that the marketplace is looking at
these assets and saying this is the
money that the government is generating
out of the asset look at how much more
can be captured if you take it into a
private regime not only her Chicago
generated more than 3.5 billion dollars
during its recent leasing spring but the
operating firms are investing millions
more in order to provide better service
many of Chicago's 36,000 meters are
being replaced by solar-powered meters
that accept credit cards and the parking
garage beneath Millennium Park now
offers shuttle service to Soldier Field
when the Bears are in town in most
publicly run assets there's efficiencies
that can be gained when you bring
revenue into the equation as the central
important function of the asset when the
government's doing it sometimes they're
not necessarily thinking about that
what is the kind of total volume of
business that's done in love if you're
speaking about dollar-wise I couldn't
answer that there are critics of course
who are uncomfortable with private
entities operating assets that have long
been run by the city others worry about
fee increases what we had in Chicago and
what you have in most cities is a
subsidized meter system and you had the
private parking garages having to
compete with that lower debt lower
number the meters were cheap but there
was no parking because the price wasn't
set to the demand cruising for street
parking is a needless waste of resources
and it contributes significantly to
downtown traffic congestion according to
studies something like 30 percent of the
congestion in downtown commercial
districts is a direct result of cruising
in Chicago today not only is there less
congestion but the private firms that
provide parking in the city are now
competing on an even playing field the
biggest opponents to privatization are
often unionized city employees like
George who are afraid to lose their jobs
but that need not be the case one of the
concessions that's been pretty common in
most of the privatizations both in the
US and and internationally is for the
existing employees of the of the
privatized system to be entitled to
continue in their in their current
function whatever that may be the
bidders will say this is what I'll bid
if it if I don't have to take on all the
existing employees and this is what I'll
bid if I do privatization is really
nothing new but it's becoming an
increasingly attractive option for
cash-strapped cities across the country
we spoke with one of the nation's
leading experts on privatization to
learn more about the process my name is
Steve Goldsmith I'm professor of
government and director of the
innovation is an American government
program and Harvard as mayor of
Indianapolis for two terms in the 1990s
Goldsmith privatized a number of city
assets as well as 80 city services
through a managed competition process
and every time we created a competitive
bidding platform on an average we save
25 percent and the cumulative effect of
those competitions is about four hundred
and fifty million dollars in savings and
more importantly every time we saved a
dollar we actually increased the quality
of the work managed competition allows
public unions to bid for contracts along
with private entities but at least at
first the unions
system in our city had seven absolutely
ins that were very anxious at the
beginning of the process they're really
mad about privatization they were
anxious about competition
but what happened over time was that men
and women who actually did the work came
out ahead because sometimes they would
bid and win sometimes they would bid and
lose but the winning vendor would take
the employees they would come up with
systems where the workers could do more
could have more discretion could earn
more money this privatization stuff
seems like a good deal for citizens and
amazingly enough for union members who
are willing to compete as well are there
other benefits one of the key benefits
in particular for Chicago with what
we've just gone through with pokévision
our history our long history is that
privatization adds transparency to
government a little transparency would
do wonders for the Cleveland metro area
where FBI agents have recently unearthed
widespread corruption among local
officials it's easier to run a
government when you don't have
commercial jobs to hand out to people
and commercial contracts to give people
it takes the candy away from the kids
it's clear that privatizing assets and
opening city services to a managed
competition process can make cities more
efficient and better able to take care
of core functions like maintaining
infrastructure but how can a city like
Cleveland generate the necessary
political consensus people who are
wealthy I can move or they can buy their
services alright so the systems today
these bureaucratic systems are unfair to
the people who are poorest and locked in
those communities so let's make the case
for change to them if the building was
sold to a private operator do you think
that would be better for you
it would be better for the general
public privatization projects generate
cash increase the quality of city
services and help make government's more
transparent
what's not to like come on Cleveland
privatize it
you